i'm gonna pick up where we left off with
peter king for my first award and it is
the smelly later julio jones award i
think he's gone i think it's done and
it's just a question of when and and how
much of the 15.3 million in fully
guaranteed money the falcons are going
to have to commit to pay to facilitate a
trade because i think they are ready to
move on from julio jones i don't think
any of this came out on monday with
multiple reporters all saying the same
thing lighting the fuse on the julio
jones trade putting everyone on notice
yeah that he's available it can't happen
until june 2nd for salary cap reasons
but i think the kyle pitts pick in my
estimation makes it even more likely
that they will move on from julio jones
and to get that second round pick they
may have to pay more of the 15.3 million
the less they pay of the 15-3 the lower
that pick is going to be and they did
get a second-round pick for muhammad
sunu not long ago which is crazy chance
they're not gonna get a second round
pick for julio jones if they're not
paying a significant amount of that 15.3
million yeah that's right i think
they're going to have to do that if they
want to get the value in return as far
as picks or assets are concerned i'm
with you all the way mike and this
certainly makes them a little bit more
expendable
uh it does and you know again we we
discussed julio jones during
uh the the trade deadline last year you
know that we thought maybe that could be
a guy that they would look to the year
was over he's getting up there in age
we've talked about how beat up he is and
all that so uh yeah that'll be something
to watch for here as we go through uh go
through otas and stuff all right
modern medical miracle superlative award
goes to modern medical miracle yes
you know this is something we talked
about yesterday jalen phillips and caleb
farley yeah baby i love it that they got
picked at least in the top 25. to me
it's arguably jaylen phillips the best
defensive player in the draft caleb
farley is second or third i mean in my
money and i'm just happy for one to see
them go but like first off let's just
hit on miami i mean miami hey i they're
they're you know to steal your phrase
mike like they're a team that's playing
chess while a lot of teams are playing
checkers the way they've mastered free
agency the draft what they did yesterday
you know jaylen waddle i think that's
the perfect pick for you know a receiver
to go along with devonte parker and
preston williams who are bigger outside
type guys and now you get
the best defensive player in the draft
pass rusher coming off the edge and they
got stud galore already on their
defensive line in their defense so
they're really building something
special and then the titans with caleb
farley i mean wow you know that's mike
frable we know he wants to play
man-to-man belichick style type of
defense and caleb barley is hands down
the best man-to-man corner in this draft
so that was awesome to see
and as long as farley has at least five
snaps in his nfl career he will be ahead
of
what they got out of their first round
pick last year in tennessee so that's
right i think they'll get more than four
snaps you have caleb farley you know the
thing about the dolphins with the jalen
phillips pick i think they sprinted to
the podium with that one that he was
still there when they used their second
pick at 18 and didn't have to trade up
to get him when you consider uh when you
consider the other teams right there you
know that could have taken do you think
the saints were trying to talk about
trading up for like him you know that's
the like you know you heard all these
rumors about the saints maybe trading up
and they honestly they took the pass
rusher
you know was it him
that they had their eye on that i mean
that's to me the guy that would make
sense but i just i'm curious
jay glazer said yesterday when they were
trying to get to the top ten it was for
a corner
i don't know if they stopped after the
top ten right they did end up with a
pass rusher that plenty of teams had as
a fourth rounder which uh is surprising
to me but the saints it was an overdraft
for sure they were kind of in no man's
land they were in a spot where they were
stuck and no opportunity to trade down
no opportunity to trade up think about
what they gave up to get marcus
davenport a few years ago i think that
you know it just it's hard to get the
right price you got to get it just right
yeah and you look at the the the
bears gave up a first round pick next
year to move from 20 to 11 but the jets
gave up two threes and got back a four
to go from 23 to 14. so you never know
what it's going to take to get one of
these deals done the next one for me is
the tom petty award which goes to mac
jones because he's already been compared
to tom petty i mean tom brady and also
there was some free falling that
happened for mac jones last night and he
always wanted to be a patriot anyway and
he's going to be even more motivated now
because he was the last of the five
quarterbacks taken so he'll be pissed
off about that 21 years from now when
he's still playing in the nfl and he
tweets out the day of the draft this is
the anniversary of the day that i went
15th and the four guys who went in front
of me are all out of the league now so
it's all set up perfectly for mac jones
as he fell from 3 to 15 chris yeah that
i mean it did it just it fell perfectly
you're right there was some sarcasm in
there well i mean i know but like it did
fall perfectly for him and i think the
patriots and you talk about like the fit
all together and everything like that
it's who everybody thought this marriage
was going to happen
from the get-go anyways and i do believe
him in the fact that he probably felt
most comfortable with the patriots and
want to be you know he came from nick
saban the patriots that's it's all the
same thing it's the same attitude you
know nick saban talks like this bill
belichick talks like this they don't
change their tone they do like this he's
gonna be coached by the same type of guy
so i mean it just seems it seemed like a
marriage made in heaven that way um
so i'm uh
i like it and of course i think he can
do dangerous things in that offense
patriots also rushed to the podium to
get that pick wait didn't they really
didn't you notice that too right like
like it was like the quickest pick of
the night when they when they saw him
there but that was and matt casey
producer here he i think he texted the
group text like did they take 30 seconds
to make that pick so they were obviously
excited that he was there
they will never admit it they will never
admit it but i think anybody who
understands
how competitive the sport is
and the emotion that goes into it
and the fact that tom brady left and won
a super bowl in his first year out of
new england
they are determined to compete with tom
brady they are playing tom brady this
year they want to be able when it's all
said and done when tom brady's done they
want to catch him just like they had
been desperate to catch the steelers
with six and very much would like to
pass them with seven they are now going
to be desperate to catch tom brady with
one
and who knows how many more
post patriots championships and mac
jones gives them the guy that did draw
the comparisons to tom brady and he
tried to downplay the comparisons before
the draft but then in that same breath
said yeah i can see why people make
comparisons so yeah they're thrilled to
get him and it's just a question of when
he supplants cam newton as the starter
now whether it's next year whether it's
during this year whether it's mac jones
versus tom brady or cam newton versus
tom brady remember remember patriots
fans cam newton all time 2-0 against tom
brady so yeah so don't don't throw cam
newton overboard just yet
no nope you're right and i don't think
they're scared to play with cam newton
or any of that so
bingo
he brought it up
haven't heard that one patriots verse
bucks brady verse whoever
um
i i mean
the
uh what i don't want to know how i want
to even phrase this here i had a phrase
in my mind here where i'd like to go
i know yes um
the freak show award okay the freak show
award that's where i want to go here and
i mean that because i'm talking about
the dallas cowboys who have become the
team that just like who's the biggest
freak available on the board who's the
biggest fastest strongest guy we'll take
him and i love the cowboys pick last
night at pick number that was 12 right i
just want to make sure i got that right
traded down got a third round pick right
and traded down to 12 with the eagles
yeah traded with the eagles and
you know michael parsons you know other
than the caleb farley and jalen phillips
that we talk about who had the medical
questions the guy that had no medical
questions that was the best defensive
player in the draft for me was michael
parsons i mean i don't know there's just
not a lot of guys on the planet earth
that are 6-3 244 and run 4-4 and can
knock your head off and can cover tight
ends and running backs and do all of
that i mean i really feel like the
seattle i mean
the dallas cowboys
with dan quinn as their new d
coordinator got their bobby wagner
that's what they got i mean this guy is
was to me one of them can't miss
prospects of the whole draft just put
him in the middle of the field six yards
off the ball and he can go be bobby
wagner dion jones miles jack fred warner
you name it that's what this guy will do
he is the perfect middle linebacker and
i really like the pick for the dallas
cowboys
and the willingness to do the trade with
the eagles and hand them devonta smith
knowing that they were going to have to
deal with devontae smith anyway because
if they didn't let the eagles get him
the giants would have gone sounds like i
would say that the cowboys would
probably prefer that he not be on the
giants because i think even though the
eagles are a big rival i think the
cowboys are more concerned about the
giants right now as they should be and
you give devonta smith to the giants
with everything else they have holy crap
so holy crap cowboys pick up an extra
third rounder and get the guy they would
have taken at 10 anyway it worked out
very well for them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports